thank you very much and as you might
expect i'm going to give you a
geological
perspective on this and i will follow in
with some of the things that vim said
about ccs i've got a lot to say so i'll
try and say it without confusing you
this photograph here you're probably
thinking why have i shown you a picture
of a
a sort of suburban street it happens to
be in blackpool
which
is quite interesting for this uh
discussion because what it shows is a
big crack that goes just underneath my
name there
and that crack was very famous in
blackpool for a short time because it
purportedly appeared after an earthquake
which was related to fracking rather
nearby that's fracking for shale gas
hydraulic fracturing and uh people said
that the frac had appeared the crack had
appeared in the bridge and people also
said that motorbikes had fallen over and
that and the traffic lights stopped
working and things like that and a lot
of people said um yes the crack appeared
and it was caused by the fracking now
the bgs detected this earthquake and our
view was there's no way that the energy
of the earthquake could have caused that
crack and and in fact if you read the
article which was attached to this
photograph if you got right down to the
bottom it said an old uh blackpool man
said in fact that crack has been there
since 1972.
so um but this this characterizes the
argument of shale gas that there's an
awful lot of stuff going on which you
can't tell is true or false and this
it's rather got worse unfortunately this
is again blackpool
and blackpool and that there are people
saying on websites that blackpool uh the
coast of blackpool is at risk of sinking
below sea level and our sea sea defenses
will have to be rebuilt essentially
there is no foundation whatsoever to
this uh it simply won't happen it's
ridiculous
and unfortunately this
sort of debate is getting wider and
wider and the public are getting fired
up with things which are are not not
true which are scientifically without
foundation so this is going to be a
little bit of
of the spirit of my talk which is the
importance of a proper debate a reasoned
and a mature debate so that we can make
good policy so that we can make good
decisions because at the moment i don't
think we can
so to a bit of science i'm sorry to show
you a graph so early but this is a
famous graph from
pacquiao and sokolo's science paper from
2004. many of you will have seen this
it's a very clever paper some people
don't like it now but at the time it was
very good because what they did was they
took the business as usual which is the
ruinous
high co2 emissions rate which might end
us up with a very high temperature rise
and they also drew a graph of the
500 parts per million stabilization
level so in other words a level of how
emissions might increase in the future
and how
they might be stabilized to develop only
a 500 parts per million which would be
safe and then they divided that triangle
up which they called the stabilization
triangle into a series of wedges which
they called stabilization wedges and
these wedges are a bit like
a scientific unit of climate abatement
if you like and what you would do is you
take one off and if you do that then
your problem gets less if you take two
off then you're getting nearer to your
um to your
ideal level so what is a wedge well a
wedge would be uh doubling global
nuclear power a wedge would be
converting two billion cars from 30
miles per gallon to 60 miles per gallon
so
two billion smart cars instead of two
billion lamborghinis um another one is
uh ccs on 800 power stations and another
one is gas and you've got to give them
credit for this because they recognized
the value of gas in 2004 they said if
you replace a substantial number of gas
power stations or a coal power stations
with gas power stations in fact 1500
gigawatts worth
of 50 efficient coal power stations you
will get a wedge
so
at also in 2004 along came shale gas in
the united states and this
picture from nature nicely shows it you
can see about 2004 2005 that's when
fracking really took off and horizontal
drilling and look where shale gas might
be in the future in 2035 it might be
producing half of america's domestic gas
an extraordinary extraordinary
projection
what does the industry think about this
well this nice appearance of shale gas
the the the tantalizing up possibility
of a wedge being offered by it well uh
this is from malcolm bridget shell who i
spoke alongside at a royal society talk
a couple of months ago who said well
displacing coal-fired power and natural
gas is the fattest fastest and cheapest
way to reduce co2 in the global power
sector it didn't really go into whether
it was with ccs or not it didn't go into
whether it was a bridge to renewables or
a backbone as bim said so in other words
we take shale gas for a while and then
when renewables are up to power then we
dump the shale gas but it wasn't quite
clear so it's not quite sure clear you
know where we are on that
of course come catch destroy is
incredibly important because
without it it's going to be very
difficult to use fossil fuels at all
so let's look at some figures now
lamentably there are very few figures
about whether shale gas or natural gas
is truly more green than other kinds of
gas or other kinds of energy the
modeling and the
work the studies haven't been done in
sufficient detail there is something
that was published by the european
commission about a month ago which was
about shale gas in relation to other
energy types and what they said was in
poland if you cha and poland is
extremely dependent is extremely
dependent for its electricity on coal
something like 90 percent of its
electricity is generated from coal if
poland converted overnight to shale gas
power stations which you probably would
like to do it would cut its emissions by
41 to 49
which is a very large cut so poland
would immediately become a lot greener
but what about the world
well essentially if we take the high gas
scenario of the iea from the golden
rules of
golden rules for a golden age of gas
it doesn't add up because they say that
you did the high gas use scenario you
get 3.5 degrees c percent warming which
is highly dangerous but of course gas
could be part of a wedge it doesn't have
to be a series of wedges it could be one
wedge but there is a problem and this is
where i'm going to make my pitch to you
there's a real problem with these wedges
i said that there are several wedges
that have been described one shale gas
two
nuclear double glue double global
nuclear power three 800 uh ccs
operations on 800 power stations
unfortunately
the public won't have it
because all those three things nuclear
shale gas and ccs all of them have the
same problem the same lack of belief
amongst the public and that might feed
through to policymakers and investors as
well they worry about it the earth is
scary people are frightened of
earthquakes look at this a somerset
expert reckons that if you do shale gas
in the mendips it'll turn into a volcano
and people believe it
you know
they p people believe it and and this is
the quality of the debate that's out
there
you know i'm not saying that shale gas
is the answer i'm not saying that ccs is
i'm not saying that double global
nuclear power either is and
but it's it's a problem because if you
if you want to do these things they're
all geological and the public
you know have many many questions about
the feasibility and the safety of it so
what am i arguing for well arguing it in
one minute yes naively i'm arguing that
science needs to take a stronger role in
this particularly independent science to
assess the risk and to do it publicly
and transparently and openly and to talk
about what's low risk things we don't
have to worry about like volcanoes and
blackpool disappearing under the irish
sea
high-risk things and there are high-risk
things there are things that we should
worry about you know like
methane getting into water supplies for
example these are things we should think
about and but the trouble is the debate
is revering over to these ridiculous
things and we get distracted and you
know what matters is the difference
between these two things if we did that
we might get a better quality debate we
might actually get better policy as well
thanks
thank you mike we do have your number
when there is a volcano in the mendips
and we'll all be on the line
let's have some questions do we have
some questions here i've got a lady at
the front already keen to get in
please thank you
thanks very much mike um jenny banks
from wwf uk um i was actually going to
ask a question quite similar to profess
professor eakins point about not
building any more coal but um
in light of the fact that's already been
asked um
just just a point really about global
fossil fuel reserves
if you look at global conventional known
reserves
about 80 percent of them can't actually
be be effectively burnt or used if we
want to stay within two degrees of
warming
and that's without looking at
unconventionals
and then if you look at the us
the claim is that that
emissions have fallen because of shale
gas and that that might be the case but
actually the coal is production is the
same it's just going elsewhere so isn't
this actually about keeping the stuff in
the ground you say that one first
and
keeping the stuff in the ground well i
think all i'm saying is that
you know i'm not advocating any of these
things i'm simply saying that if you
want to do them
you're going to have to communicate the
science better and and the risks you
know to the public better otherwise
we're not going to have these wedges
i'm not advocating shale gas or nuclear
or anything else i'm a public public
servant so i don't do that sort of thing
i'm simply here to explain what i think
is the issue and the main issue is if
you want to have
you know fossil fuels
or nuclear
you know or or shale gas
well
you're going to have to be able to
address these issues otherwise it's not
going to happen
but it does sound odd for you to say
yeah though you're of course public
servant that if you want any of them i
mean you you must have a view on some
sort of preference or some sort of risk
that attaches to one and not to another
yeah i mean there are
as i said there are risks for example to
do with earthquakes in fracking in in
shale gas and
you know and there are there is science
that we can do to mitigate those risks
there are there's signs that we can do
to develop a procedure whereby a company
that might frack um can can be slowed
down there could be a traffic light
system whereby if they get to an
earthquake of a certain size it can be
told to stop fracking that that's the
appliance of science if you like to use
a term
an advertising term you know that um
that shows how you can do this but um
you have to do the work in other words
in order to you know distinguish low
risk from high risk
yeah any right let's take some more
questions we've got one over here and
the gentleman in the blue jumper i'll
try and take this gentleman at the front
next so we might take these two together
if you do hello i'm like robert page i'm
studying geology at imperial
and possibly if people like the wwf
greenpeace the bbc and the guardian
didn't fill the public's imagination
with such scare mongering there might be
a chance for the proper science to have
an independent look
and actually
possibly if we stop bashing the energy
companies can the whole time might be
discovered that the wind farms they
dream of don't actually solve any energy
problems and possibly don't help our co2
either so
you obsess with bringing down co2 but
maybe
the way to do that is through gas and
then we both have an energy supply which
we can rely on
and we help the environment
that's the bbc told uh and yes sir the
front
thank you tony cousin price from open
democracy and intelligence squared um
i'm interested to know mike whether you
think that there's a
is there a science to the
perception of risk i'm quite struck by
the fact that in the u.s somehow other
it seems as if these perceptions of risk
have uh gone a different way
might that be linked to
different interests that people have i
mean after all in the u.s if you own a
piece of land then you own the geology
underneath it does does the perception
of risk depend on our institutions in
that sort of way yeah of course and you
hit on it quite rightly that um you know
in the united states if you have shale
gas under your farm or your house then
you stand to gain from it directly in
britain you don't so that changes the
argument quite a bit and there is an
extremely well developed science of risk
and you can be sure that we're working
on this and you know
british regulators take on the science
of risk you know very fully and very
rigorously
but
you know
we've seen this already we know that we
have amongst the the best and tightest
regulations for offshore gas uh offshore
oil and gas in in the world and you know
generally the north sea has been
extremely successful
in in doing that in in regulating
properly making sure it's safe with a
few unfortunate you know uh exceptions
but the people of blackpool don't don't
take that you know
they don't want that and
and again i'm not
i don't want to be seen as somebody
who's pushing fossil fuels at all i'm
saying that
you know if you want to have them then
the science has to be properly community
communicated and just going to the
gentleman's com comment
i don't agree with what you're saying
about greenpeace and you know world
wildlife fund because these are all
people
who contribute to the debate and who
make us think you know beyond you know
if we are a fossil fuel
company whatever you think beyond that
and it's important to have all those
stakeholders in the argument and in the
discussion
so um
and they often put over the science very
well i mean occasionally you know it
might be over overwrought and but this
stuff about you know mendips volcanoes
isn't coming from world wildlife fund or
greenpeace
um
yeah but yeah
well i mean i think that your your point
is later so shall we move on to
you